The Joe Rogan Experience it's like
Anderson Silva man that broke my heart
when you lost to Jake Paul Bro and like
hey you got this little kid bro like you
know and he doing his thing right you
see that he's an athlete you see that
he's working on his uh his style of
fighting you know I mean when it comes
to boxing but at the end of the day it's
still he picking up he picking at every
MMA hit right and he he's fighting Tyron
Willie Ben Ashton now Anderson Silva and
then guess who he said probably gonna be
next right Jake Paul no um uh Andrew
Tate oh actually they just posted they
just face they just FaceTime but the
name the name that he was talking about
was Diaz though yeah first at first well
the Diaz fight is a big name and a big
money fight but he's a lot bigger he's a
lot bigger but that's that's the point
yeah he wants as much
he is doing it smart but at the same
time he embarrassing all of us like for
real like and it's sad because like he's
saying all these different things and
he's talking about and having these real
conversations that need to be had but
it's coming from him he's not money you
are you know but it's not but it's not a
conversation for him to have but it is
it is because it helps him get attention
and okay I love what he's doing I hate
it I hate it I want to be today
but you're a fighter and I'm gonna get a
check for it too yeah but it's not it's
not because I'm just a fighter because
he's telling us that we're not even
brave enough to fight for ourselves so
I'm gonna fight for y'all while I'm
knocking out y'all Legends in the
process of it yeah he's what he's doing
is very intelligent I don't know it's
it's the promotions off the chart he's
hilarious he's he's Brash and he's
winning and he's winning but is who he's
winning against though yeah but Anderson
Silva you gotta say that's the most
impressive fight that he won you got to
say Anderson Silva is a legend maybe
he's 47 years old but that's the thing I
had Jake Paul to win
I knew Jake Paul was going to win just
because the age is so you know I mean
and then uh on top of that I didn't see
Jake Paul knocking out Anderson either
though you understand I just knew it
would be competitive uh enough for Jake
Paul to take it you know what I'm saying
take the win uh but at the same time
it's just like bro like
if you fought Anderson when he was you
know saying in his prom
where you getting knocked out right but
like you talking about most certainly in
an MMA fight mostly not even most
certainly in the MMA fight like Anderson
used to box boxes bro and that's the
thing too I hate about MMA dudes like
since we on here like a lot of these
dudes be like ah box Canelo or our box
you know what I'm saying Mayweather and
all this stuff but never getting the
actual ring and uh uh just train and
spar with actual real boxes from like
whatever the neighborhood you know what
I'm saying like I used to actually box
with the guys from the neighborhood and
Page their boxing like Josh uh Temple
you know uh uh uh von Alexander
Alexander's brother you know like I had
to actually work with actual boxers to
realize oh this is a different type of
game yes you know but when you just
boxing with the guys that's in the MMA
room and you're thinking like because
you touching them that's you pretty
decent you gonna find out if you
actually get in with a real boxer before
you actually compete with them yeah you
you don't know what you're doing you
know because it's certain little
combination and there's certain like
cages that we do as MMA fighters that
will get us knocked out from a boxer you
have you thought about competing as a
boxer
but the thing is though it's so deluded
because the the whole perception of MMA
guys want to box is because of money
because I would never just get into it
for money my biggest thing is I will
actually commit myself to the sport of
boxing I would get me a boxing coach
like when uh even George St Pierre like
I feel like he could have been pretty
decent you know had a great jab in MMA
but you see he was working with who
Freddie Roach right you know right and
uh Anderson Silva also found a boxing
coach I I figured who he was working
with as well but you could see him that
he was training that art of boxing and
he was could actually compete in the
actual ring so you would need a timeline
you would need yeah it definitely how
much time do you think you would need
oh well since I've already been working
with boxes for a minute and I got a
great uh boxing coach at the STL boxing
uh Reggie Thomas shout out to him uh I
probably only need like two three years
to actually find me a profile
you know and actually work but that's a
realistic assessment I'm glad you said
that two three years is correct oh yes
sir yeah you can't just hop into right
your time ain't just gonna work for all
right yeah and be and then I'm not just
gonna call out the best in the world
right you know pound for pound I'm gonna
work my way up right I'm gonna get some
Knockouts I'm gonna get some good little
names I'm gonna get some prospects and
then I'm like once y'all see I got a
resume now now let's see what them names
talking about